welcome back to the Rich Eisen show not
just you the viewers and listeners but
my next guest who's chillin out right
here his first hour-long comedy special
the ugly truth premieres Friday July the
7th 9th on Showtime a big clipper fan
wearing his Raider jacket Eric Griffin
good to see you sir I'm born and raised
in LA so I remember so this is a Los
Angeles Raiders well it's a I got this
you know putting our budgets in San
Diego which I thought was kind of weird
it's hard to get out of the city with
this like yeah it's like one of those
old school days oh yeah starter one I
love this yeah it's a bay it sort of
looks like a baseball jacket you see the
pitcher put on when he gets on your head
around the bases you know what I mean
for the third-base coach exactly it's a
particularly windy night in San
Francisco and it's got the a on the
right land sleeve for the American
Football Conference that is old I came
with him to go to Vegas I'm a degenerate
gambler so it's going to be perfect you
think that's a gator Friday and it's
interesting that they're that they are
one of their a very rare situation where
a team that is announced its intention
to leave yeah and they do it years in
advance can you even imagine being in
like a relationship with someone and you
tell your girl listen boo boo um I'm
leaving in two years this is for a
better situation but in the meantime
let's make this work again and and and
that the person who can actually make it
work between you and your boo is
Marshawn Lynch yep that's a guy who camp
comes in and makes it all work but he is
for the lack of a better phrase which is
a great way to infuse it he's like a
human shield yeah yeah for the franchise
with the fans of Oakland to say if he's
coming back but that would make me so
mad like if you're a real fan in Oakland
you're almost mad that they did that
you're mad that they brought in this guy
that's going to make you still cheer for
the team still knowing that they're
going to leave the only thing that can
make up for this is that the Raiders
make this Super Bowl in our next two
years which is very possible
yes very possible for them to make it
you know yeah you don't know what Tom
Brady played 12 games last year it's a
four more games on his schedule five
more however many more games you would
have played that makes a difference
and Eddie you had 12 more touchdown
passes no this guy I know that guy you
homer from Boston to you that I get
normally you wear a Red Sox hat but
today is a today's a good day for him
he's gonna this guy's going to fall fast
unfortunately no no one has no one's
gone just long and played at that level
at this age I don't care what is diet is
not it's a great diet by the way who
cares I mean it's a hell of grown men
right at you at extreme speeds with
extreme strength you know cuz listen
he's a field goal kick away you know if
Atlanta Atlanta had some sense we would
be talking about how old he looked in
the first half of that game that was at
halftime of that game if you checked out
yeah you heard reverse was put in Jimmy
G and this is the end on Brady it's all
over brace for a degenerate you know and
then the second half was crazy train
comedian Eric Griffin here on the Rich
Eisen showed you are you keeping your
clipper season tickets yes I'm free you
know what I thought about it I thought I
had to question myself I was like a mile
like a bandwagon er but I'm for my way
how could a clipper fan ever be cused of
being a bad boy because this little run
they've had the diss little like pretend
run in the last five years
I mean jay-z run yeah yeah yeah you know
with starting with Blake Griffin getting
hurt and then like actually the Blake
Griffin Chris apartment hurt the whole
time they know it's been a
disappointment really but I thought did
I just get this because of that but no
I'm from LA I go back to Terry D hair
daily to hair I'm a real good old Terry
to hair and the halls finest Terry to
him nobody bought you know oh yeah so I
thought look walk went to Michigan so
I'm like I'm a real clipper fan and I
love these are the lows we have these
but they're like 15-year loss you know
what we had Larry Brown so I'm a bit I'm
a big sound like it and I'd like to
where the direction is going getting
Jerry West having Steve Ballmer is going
to get it a new stadium but I'm a little
iffy with Doc right now you have to pick
one of the three you can't be president
of basketball operations players coach
and father
you got pick one bro you got to pick one
because these jobs you messing up the
other jobs with this job because even if
the Carmelo Anthony you know deal was
not real he says if the preferential
treatment is happening and that drove
Chris Paul away that's a problem if him
being a good GM because he's like trying
to be loyal to players that you know
he's not a good GM it's messing with
that pick one be a coach
be a dad or be the president of
basketball operations that's what doc I
don't know look I'm not going to say the
information that is put out there is is
wrong I just find it very hard to
believe that Doc Rivers is offered
Carmelo Anthony and Sasha Sasha
booyah Chooch for two old guys and I
Jamal Crawford to Michigan guy so it's
tough for me to just call him an old guy
he's more than that it's all about the
money the Hall Pierce and Austin Rivers
I don't think doc is saying I can't make
that trade because I'm coaching my son
there's no well he's already hands he's
already over paying his son
that's why jayjay wedeck's out he's
going to be out of here - imagine you're
like a starter and and the coach's kid
is making more money than you on the
bench I'd be like get him out of here so
you know but just think of the money I
don't know how much Carmelo the
ridiculous deal he has absurd so with
like Austin Rivers 11 million a year or
whatever he's making plus Paul Pierce's
like you know farewell tour money that
he was making you know I think it's
probably evened out but even still man
the preferential treatment thing is not
good but here's the thing - I don't
think this is going to work Chris Paul
and James Harden have a history of I
don't want to use the word choke okay
but let's sound like he just did not
show up in big moments in the playoffs
in the past five six years neither one
of them shows up in big moments okay so
now they're gonna be together
I think I'll cancel each other out and
have a big moment together they're gonna
have a big moment together because they
haven't had big moments days they've had
like some really actually awful moments
it just strikes me hard to believe that
Chris Paul versus Plus James Harden does
not equal one playoff win series playoff
win okay and the first round right
well I mean for Chris Paul he's got to
get to the third round I never done that
I which is truly remarkable but how is
this gonna I don't know if this makes
them any better than the two top teams
in the in the West ballroom I don't
think the now Minnesota's going to be in
the mix Eric Griffin comedian airproof
in here Showtime specialty ugly truth
Friday next Friday 9:00 Eastern on
Showtime I don't think that the
Rockettes team we're seeing right now is
the Rockettes team that is going to be
not done yet tipping it off
next what late October or early November
I guess their start or no October
because they're sort of earlier yeah a
week early they decided they're going to
they're going to pad the season by a
week so they'll say you don't need to
rest your superstars like LeBron when
were you at that clipper Cavs game that
don't Ronnie when I started that with
that I should have sold that ticket I
should have sold that ticket it really I
don't care you want to rest rest but you
give the fans a week notice so I know
that I know I'm not going to go to this
if I know but I want to go to this game
or people that bought tickets oh that's
a yes you were at that game how was that
people were so mad at the game there was
people like because people sold tickets
and people are just like $600 it is I
paid $1,000 for this and I was like oh I
got some pretty good seats me and Adam
Devine on from you know we got so which
should we sit like three away okay you
know so it was pricey I'm a little bit
like I hope we have a good season yet
external hard yeah yeah it's kind of
like that's what made me think am i real
fan as like yes I am
I've invested it said that's the most
expensive thing I've ever bought in my
acting comedy career that's my guilty
pleasure but you know that was these
superstars rest rest at home okay rest
at one time you go on a Saturday night
game rest at home
it's exciting atmosphere the NBA is
going to be doing something about that I
think in the next two weeks but I don't
know how you could tell you're and and
then and I don't how you could tell your
your teams that you have to you cannot
rest players on the road and then when
it all comes down to it LeBron was being
it was talking about how LeBron and the
Cavs did run out of gas at the end of
their run but worldly lives only really
talking about LeBron James and like a
couple other people
well the Cooper's did it a lot too yeah
I don't even travel Griffin and DeAndre
Jordan sick again no not on purpose I
mean they just disguise never stay
healthy that's true they're still a
Griffin they talking about Iman play
till December they're talking about
right now where did you shoot the ugly
truth I did it at Long Beach Long Beach
at the Long Beach Laugh Factory
it was great I look I really hope people
enjoy it it's just me I've been in the
business for like 13 years now and it's
like a cumulation of all this fun
material and I'm proud of it not you
know watch it tweet at me let me know
what you think
okay tweet at you at Eric with a Kay
Griffin on Twitter again it's next
Friday
July 7th 90s turn on Showtime don't be a
stranger don't I 1/2 years to come I
can't wait to see what sports
memorabilia I will have on like next
time I come I guess you will be a Tom
Brady Jersey and take it out on Aaron
back in 60 seconds with NFL officiating
news that I think you're going to enjoy
that's next year in the Rich Eisen show
the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to